und dann hier noch kurzen armen er in
schönster damit es nicht auffällt
ich komme gerne mal vorbei an euren
laden da ausgedacht und herzlich
willkommen zurück es ist ein wunder
geschehen auf diese macht schulden würde
ich wohl kurz einmal ein haken auf
diesem wunderschönen kanal zu einem
neuen video jetzt hast du das jetzt ist
es spät okay leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht es gut und sie lebt noch immer
werden die kamera so lange nicht benutzt
jetzt schon ganz dreckig geworden schon
besser ja wir haben uns heute hier
wieder zusammengefunden auf kanal auf
dem wirklich in letzter zeit nicht bekam
ich weiß wir können uns mal kurz
hinsetzen dann erkläre ich dass ich es
passiert ich habe mir letztens die einer
million abonnenten erreicht noch einmal
dankeschön dafür
und dann habe ich mir gedacht ich möchte
natürlich weiter viele videos hier
machen
allerdings hatte ich vor diesen 1
millionen an von ich will so viele
videos wie möglich machen ich will diese
einem newsnetz möglich erreichen
und jetzt habe ich dir erreicht und
jetzt will ich wirklich natürlich immer
noch viele videos bringen allerdings nur
noch videos wo ich sagen sind geil die
würde ich mir selber absolut gerne geben
und nicht halt alles mitnehmen was kommt
und das wäre schon längst wieder weiter
gegangen das problem ist ich habe so
viel bestellt ihr könnt ja meine
rutschten china unboxing usw
das ist alles noch nicht da weil sehr
viele lieferanten verzögerungen haben
das dauert alles so ewig hab mich schon
vor einer halben stelle sind wir nicht
da und das fakt halt ein bisschen ab
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht gut die
sachen kommen nicht zu mir dann komme
ich halt zu den sachen und habe heute
geschockt wir machen heute nämlich
erstmal direkt zwei videos und das erste
ist genial
ich habe mir gedacht okay airport es
sind schon sehr lange her ist der letzte
part kam
du gehst du zu saturn und kaufst da den
günstigsten airport fake den es so gibt
und dann habe ich hier den style
im moment muss ich selber tws btv 7
gefunden
wie teuer 39 99 88 nämlich noch
verstehen was da für ein zeug ist und
wie teuer das eigentlich in china ist
auf jeden fall ist das modell was mehr
als noch gar nichts sagt tws btv 7 etwas
ganz neues klingt sehr exotisch guest
gar nicht am anfang und es kann doch
nicht sein leute ich hab dir jetzt
wirklich guck mal hier gibt es
anscheinend bei media markt saturn und
ideal für 39 99 haben wir eine rezension
von 3,1 jack ass also ich eigentlich
gibt es ja alle bluetooth airports
irgendwo günstiger so nah gut mal was
neues ich würde sagen ich bin gespannt
ja wir sind ja immer noch das ist zwar
ich weiß es ist selber her
wir sind immer noch bei dem die 1000 ev
ist die waren gut die kosten 30 euro und
mal schauen ob das hier die übertreffen
kann
das kommando juli auf jungs google
stellt sogar meinen namen geil da habe
ich nicht mitbekommen
es war so klar dass du den pink genommen
sollte ein kind gelesen habe wusste ich
dass den punkt also ja klar wenn schon
denn schon oder ich meine ist auf kreise
hast du schon mal pinkl gesehen
die haben wieder diese clark funktion
alter führen ist das wieder so ein paket
für 93 79 30 99 ich glaub das ist ach du
scheiße war schon dieser name von den
dingern von style ist verrückt dass ich
an jeder böses das gibt das kann doch
nicht dein ernst sein von hier
betrachtet sieht das halt auch wieder
schon echt für 40 euro absolut absolut
abscheidung vor allem das ist natur da
erwarten wir noch qualität oder nicht
und dann kriege ich hier so was wie
die sehen genauso aus wie diese tracks
dinge die ich damals für 15 geschossen
hat und dies im internet für 4 euro gibt
das also wenn die wenn das diese und
wenn ich das jetzt herausstellt
bodenlose frechheit also das ist ja
abzocke und dann hier noch kurz den
namen geändert schöne new ones teil
damit es nicht auffällt ja ich komme
dann noch mal vorbei an euren saturn
laden da okay gut wir wollen jetzt hier
nicht vorverurteilen starten wir mal
oder guck mal auch dieser knopf viel
wenn ich das schon höre
und dann dieses leuchten ein das kennen
wir doch alles schon
ich dachte ich habe jetzt was neues
gefunden wieso eine brotdose okay zack
zack haben die die bei dieser ton auch
heute anscheinend schon da er immerhin
gibt es in verschiedenen farben
dann schauen wir mal wie die heißen
wahrscheinlich eines teil oder und weißt
du wo die lage die lage ganz vorne an
der kasse so schön zum haufen direkt wo
alle lang fehlen lagen die für 39 99 und
sich damit sich wahrscheinlich jede
mutter denken ach da mache ich meine
kinder meine freude airports
und dann kommt sowas warum das kind
fühlt sich so für eure hanna hattest du
das nicht auch mal dass die ultra was
gewünscht ist und seinem arm hat die
genau das täusche die kaufen ja ich habe
auch bei mir früher gar nicht gecheckt
ich hatte mal so ein game eutingen und
ich dachte er ist immer das wäre
wirklich ein gameboy sich da mal
erfahren habe das ist absolut kein game
boy das war irgendwo ein fake aus dem
flugzeug connected tvs btv 7
und das fühlt sich die führen sie auch
schon so an wie a wie so als wäre halt
gar nichts drin wäre okay wir machen es
wie immer erstmal einen soundcheck dann
mikrofon check wann haben wir denn das
mikrofon check gemacht und distanz shaq
hast den guten song
manchmal kann weil tauchen kann weil
schon vor weiß egal karneval hits 2020
[Musik]
nein zum fc köln
ich weiß was die der sound von diesem
weg grad ist ungefähr so witzig wie das
ist absolut das ist eine schweinerei
diese dinger das sind genau die gleichen
das sind die i7 tws passt auch ich zeig
euch das jetzt ich hoffe ihr habt davon
ab welche altersgruppen auf jeden fall
viele verloren ich habe gleich junge das
schnell was ist das kann ja das ist so
ein skandal oder ja das kannst du doch
nicht machen
ich habe ja bei tätig schon gesagt okay
15 euro dafür finde ich schon krass aber
39 99 alter das ist diese hier habe ich
für vier euro für zwei euro bei ihm
gekauft zwei euro die haben nicht
verlost weil diese scheiße waren und das
ist einfach genau das gleiche
das ist doch ich weiß nicht was ich dazu
sagen soll
ich frage mich halt wer sich die mühe
macht und daher auch die dramedy pink
leitet ja auch nicht blöd die die leute
aber das ist doch das ist doch einmal so
das kannst du doch nicht machen oder
kupfer heute gibt euch dass das ist
möglich ich habe 40 euro in sand gesetzt
die mülltonne hat absolut das einfach
komplett guck mal hier
hier steht auch noch monster drauf das
haben die sich hier gespart also im für
den aufruf monster gehen dann halt auch
mal verträglicher weise 98 eur nach oben
weil bonns reihe das ist schon eine sehr
gefragte krasse merkel ein unterschied
habe ich jetzt gefunden
sie ist toll
vom fahrzeug des opfers ist genau das
gleiche wie diese hier brutal schnell
grausam schlecht
also wir können sie gerne nochmal dem
mikrofon check machen jetzt zu ende aber
ich fahre gleich zum saturn und tauschte
ich sagte ihnen dass ich bin nämlich der
experte und nicht die ich sagte ihm dass
wie es ist und was sie sich dabei denkt
manchmal von inside story extratouren
stimmt gute idee
leute wir sind hier gerade wieder am
videos drehen und ich wollte mal ganz
kurz ihr euch was zeigen und zwar reicht
gerade im saturn und habe da ordentlich
eingekauft unter anderem auch wieder
airport fakes wir haben hier
dieses ding gekauft die du dir all style
die gibt es bei saturn und media markt
für 39 99 alles 20 euro
und hier habe ich jetzt getestet und
dann ist mir aufgefallen moment ihr
könnt sie doch und das sind einfach
genau die gleichen die ich damals bei
jugend für zwei euro gekauft habe das
ist doch alle dafür liegt jetzt war okay
ja gut ich wirklich mal trotzdem einmal
kurz an und dann mikrofon geht
vielleicht sogar klar bin ich mal
gespannt
also ich verstehe nicht ganz gut nur
sagen außer mit den linken denken jetzt
kann man ja nichts anderes machen als
ein bisschen flexen oder sieht selbst
das scheiße aus absolut für die ducks
immer wenn ich wenn ich mit den dingern
mit diesen finken dinge an einen sehen
würde
ich würde ihn fragen hast du weißt du
wenn du damit einen der wahnsinn
das dauert das ist echt nicht gut für
das gefühl fürs ohr glaube die tasche um
die 40 euro hole ich mir wieder ein
kleiner nachtrag ich hab gelesen und
komma hier steht sogar drauf wo die
herkommen
die kommt von einem von der deutschen
adresse es ist ja ganz das ist ganz
dubios ich checke also oder diese dinger
kommen zu 100 prozent aus spenden aus
china
ich weiß nicht was ist das ist ich weiß
nicht was ich dazu sagen soll das ist
ganz ganz schlimm finde ich also da habe
ich jetzt auch ein bisschen das
vertrauen verloren obwohl ich sehr gerne
oft bei media markt oder saturn mal was
eingekauft habe man vertraut den ja
irgendwie schade schade schade
er hat leute ich weiß das video weiß
nicht zu krass aber wir haben hier was
krasses aufgedeckt meiner meinung nach
und deswegen hatte ich hoffe ich auch
für euch gelohnt das video zu schauen
abonniert auf jeden fall den kanal
wir sehen uns spätestens morgen oder
übermorgen wieder aber jetzt kommen wir
auf jeden fall wieder geregelt videos
und ich hoffe nächsten woche geht es
dann auch weiter mit dem ganzen china
bestellung weil da kann ich so viele
videos raushauen und freut euch auf
jeden fall da raus und aber diesen kanal
ins normale check auf jeden fall einen
neuen kanal ab da kommen fast täglich
videos hoch sein